COMPELLING PIECE OF TAPE WHY
DIDN’T CONGRESSMAN CASTRO SHOW
THE ENTIRE CLIP?
JOINING US IS THE TRUMP
DEFENSE ATTORNEY DAVID SCHOEN.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO USE AS
MUCH VIDEO AS THEY CAN.
IT’S AWFUL.
IT LOOKS AWFUL.
YOUR TEAM STIPULATED TO THE
FACT THAT IT WAS AWFUL.
NO ONE CONDONING ON ANYTHING
THAT HAPPENED ON THAT DAY.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO OFFER
SIMILAR, COMPELLING AND
EMOTIONAL VIDEO SHOWING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS, THEMSELVES,
THAT THIS IS THE STANDARD
COULD BE INCITED ALL SORT OF
THE RIOTOUS BEHAVIOR?
>> WELL, THAT YOU HAVE TO
STAND BY AND WATCH.
IT’S A PRETTY GOOD BET.
I WOULD SAY THAT IT’S NOT ONLY
THEY WANTED PLENTY OF VIDEO
TIME TODAY BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY WANT SCREEN TIME FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE PLAYING TO THE
CAMERA, TO THE PUBLIC ALL THE
TIME.
I OFFER TO STIPULATE IN THE
OPENING ADDRESS THAT I MADE TO
THE, THAT THE RIOT HAPPENED.
IT WAS HORRIFIC AND SO ON.
I SAID YOU TALK ABOUT UNITY
AND HEALING.
SHOWING THAT TAPE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN SAME SLIDES AND SO
ON, MANIPULATED BY THEM DOES
NOTHING FOR THE HEALING.
IT’S THE OPPOSITE.
IT’S CONTINUING TO OPEN WOUNDS
FOR THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONDEMNED IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS THE TERRIBLE VIOLENCE
THAT WENT ON.
THERE IS NO ISSUE ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE HOPING TO DRUM UP
ELECTIONS AND GET THE LAST
SHOT IN AT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: YOU SAY TONIGHT
THAT YOU WILL SHOW BECAUSE THE
VIDEOTAPE IS OUT THERE WHAT
THE IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS
THEMSELVES SAID ABOUT THE
WORTH OF PREVIOUS ELECTION,
NAMELY 2016, OR OTHER WORDS
SIMILAR TO THAT.
THAT COULD BE SIMPLY DESCRIBED
AS INCITING UNREST.
>> YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF WHAT
IS OUT THERE.
I DON’T COMMIT TO ANY PUBLIC
STRATEGY WE WILL USE.
I DON’T THINK IT’S WISE.
BUT YOU WILL BE IMPRESSED WITH
THE PRESIDENT’S CASE.
I SAY THAT, WITHOUT WANTING TO
HAVE TO DO THAT.
WE SHOULDN’T BE HERE.
THIS IS ILLEGITIMATE,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS.
COMPLETELY LACKING IN ANY --
>> Laura: I KNOW BUT YOU
LOST THAT POINT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT YOU LOST THAT POINT.
WE GET IT.
I MEAN I UNDERSTAND THAT
ARGUMENT.
I’M A LAWYER.
YOU LOST THAT POINT SO NOW
IT’S GOING BACK TO INCITEMENT.
I’LL ASK AGAIN.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT DON’T
FOLLOW THE LAW.
THEY DON’T FOLLOW THE LAW.
THEY DON’T KNOW THE LAW OR THE
LAW OF IMPEACHMENT SO THEY SEE
ALL THE VIDEO.
THEN THEY SEE ALL THE TRUMP
TWEETS.
THEY SEE THE FACT HE DIDN’T
IMMEDIATELY COME OUT AND
CONDEMN IT AND TELL THEM TO GO
HOME.
THEY SAY IT’SER TOABLE.
HE DID INCITEMENT.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW THE OTHER
SIDE MORNING NOON AND NIGHT
FOR MOST OF THE TRUMP’S
PRESIDENCY.
IT IS A HINT.
GIVING YOU A HINT HERE.
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
RELEVANT.
YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF WHAT IS
OUT THERE.
>> Laura: A HINT.
THIS IS WHAT IMPEACHMENT
MANAGER TED LU SAID TODAY.
>> HOW DO YOU GET TO POINT
WHERE THE RIOTERS DESECRATED,
DEFILED AND DISHONORED YOUR
SENATE CHAMBER?
I WILL SHOW YOU HOW WE GOT
HERE.
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP RAN OUT
OF NONVIOLENT OPTIONS TO
MAINTAIN POWER.
>> Laura: DAVID, WOULD HE BE
THROWN OUT OF COURTROOM IN A
REGULAR PROCEEDING SAYING
SOMETHING SO OUTLANDISH?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY WOULD BE THROWN OUT OF A
COURTROOM FOR SHOWING THIS
VIDEO.
NONE OF THIS STUFF IS
ADMISSIBLE IN ANY COURT OF
LAW.
THAT IS PART OF THE DUE
PROCESS ISSUE.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU SAW TODAY
MIKE LEE STOOD UP AND OBJECTED
THAT THEY FALSELY ATTRIBUTED
TO HIM STATEMENTS HE NEVER
MADE.
HE MADE AN OBJECTION AND THE
PLACE BLEW UP IN A HULLABALOO.
AND RASKIN SAID THEY WOULD
WITHDRAW IT NOW AND CHECK THE
SOURCES.
THE "WASHINGTON POST," HE
MIGHT HAVE SAID.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CLIPS THEY
SHOW SOME SOURCES ARE
REPORTEDLY, AND OTHERS ARE
SOURCES SAID.
HEARSAY, HEARSAY, HEARSAY.
HE WAS OUTRAGED BECAUSE THEY
MADE AN ARGUMENT AND
ATTRIBUTED COMMENTS TO HIM
THAT HE SAID A CALL MADE TO
HIM WITHOUT CONSULTING HIM
ABOUT WHAT WAS SAID IN THE
CALL.
IMAGINE THAT?
DISRESPECT TO A SENATOR.
>> Laura: SCHUMER BLEW IT
OFF LIKE IT DOESN’T AFFECT THE
CASE.
IT WAS COMPELLING.
DAVID, I WANT TO ASK --
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT WAS.
>> Laura: FAIR POINT.
I WANT TO ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION.
GIVEN WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE
FOR THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PRECEDENT AND THE FACT THEY
WANT TO CANCEL TRUMP
OPPORTUNITY TO RUN AGAIN IF HE
WANTS TO, HAVE YOU CONSULTED
THE PRESIDENT’S PREVIOUS
IMPEACHMENT TEAM, JAY SEKULOW
AND THAT CROWD, GIVEN THEY
WERE SUCCESSFUL?
NOT SAYING YOU WON’T BE
SUCCESSFUL, YOU PROBABLY WILL
BE.
BUT YOU HAVE COLLABORATED WITH
THAT TEAM?
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO THEM.
YES.
>> Laura: FANTASTIC.